what's the upside of this lifestyle
i really [ __ ] love drugs so
i get to be on them
all right moser
moser where'd you grow up where are you
from originally um
i grew up in allentown
in that area
but i moved to l.a right when i was like
right after high school
so
i feel like i really grew up in l.a
in a sense
and you had mom and dad growing up
oh i was raised mostly by my dad
my mom
she left when i was like
12 i think
ken
came back around right when i left why
do you think your mom left oh i don't
know that's her business
how you describe your childhood in
general um
it was
i don't know
i'm not sure
it was
kind of typical
what kind of kid were you in high school
very popular
but um
naina
not a cliche way
i don't know i was more
i got along with everybody
but i also got a lot of trouble
um you finished high school i did yeah i
actually got expelled from the same high
school twice
but they still gave me my diploma
cause i was close okay
and what did you do after high school
moved to l.a
and when you came to l.a you did what
drugs
yeah
where were you staying on the street
on skid row or somewhere else in west
l.a and then
i would stay with i had a lot of
girlfriends
so i would
you know
bounce around between them
i live with a lot of women
how would you make money
um
how did i make money
my girls took care of me
you know
and what drugs were you doing at the
time heroin heroin
yeah
that was how old do you know
now i'm
30.
and so i started when i was
like 20.
he came to kensington when
well i moved to
back to allentown
first
and i used to come up here
like every day
for drugs
but
then
some things happened some life changes
my girl left me
and
i just had a lot of
a lot of things ended and changed so i
ended up staying here
my cars broke down
i was no longer going to be able to come
here to cop every day
so
here i am
how long you been here
about a year and a half
what happened to your voice
uh
i hit something i'm not supposed to
while i was shooting up
and every time it starts coming back i
[ __ ] do it again
because this is where i hit on my neck
but
you know doing in the dark how long has
your voice been out like this been about
a week and a half now
so
at least now i can somewhat talk
right when i first do it there's nothing
yeah yesterday you were worse
tell me about living in kensington
no i mean
all i want to do is drugs
and die
so it's pretty perfect do you think you
have a death wish
i do but i don't i guess yeah
you know
as much sense as that makes yeah if you
really want to die you just jump in
front of a train yeah it's not that i
want to die like
i don't
vehemently want to die
but i'm open to it
you know
you call yourself self-destructive yeah
definitely yeah
and where do you think that comes from
something in your childhood that
happened or something you heard
i think i'm just kind of done in a way
um
i just don't want to do everything i
i just don't want to do it again you
know my wife is gone
my
i just done
i've done what i've wanted to do or i
feel like i need to do i don't want to
start over
i just wanted you to do the work of
getting clean
no i don't wanna clean
i don't wanna i don't wanna kick again
i don't wanna be clean again
i mean your option is is pretty bleak
then
yeah yeah
it's just what i want to do
so
this is a great place to do it yes it is
do you have kids or anything
no
no kids
your family knows that you're in this
situation
my family knows that i am this situation
and they've given up on you no
but what can they do no they're not
gonna stop you if you're not gonna
cooperate
what do you think would change your mind
but what do you think would get you to
tell me nothing
i'll
i'll decide to do something productive
eventually
you think
oh i won't
yeah every time i drive past you in the
park i see you putting a needle in your
neck yeah or putting a needle in someone
else's someone else's
yeah
that's how i make money here
people pay you too good
to find a vein to hit them right
and why the neck because the veins in
your arm or legs are gone that's that's
just where
yeah that's where we go that's where
it's where it works it's pretty
interesting to drive through
especially like the
needle park in kensington
and you'll see five or six or seven
people in a row
just openly
injecting probably fentanyl
yeah in their necks necks feet yeah
wherever they can right
and when they can't they come to me
is that right you're
you're a specialist funny
yeah
no abscesses nothing like that no
your hands are rough though yeah i mean
i've definitely had
i have plenty of
of
wear you know all over
what's the upside of this lifestyle
i really [ __ ] love drugs so
i get to be on them
what's so great about them
i mean
i guess you have to do it
is there anything that you're running
from hiding from that you went through
as a kid or something like that i don't
think so
if i am doing a really good job of it
yeah you just you just discovered drugs
and
no i feel like i've always
i don't know
i feel like i've always been an addict
you know are there addicts in your
family
no
no no
no
do you have any regrets in your life
no
your legacy is going to be you were a
drug addict that died in their 30s
unless something changes right
probably
people die from fentanyl every day
oh yeah i know
if it isn't fentanyl it'll be a dirty
needle or something like that right
um
it'll be something it could be a bullet
yeah it could be a point out here
but um
this is always how i don't know
like i said i'll decide to do something
and
i'll be great at it
or i won't
and i'll die what are you good at what
would you like to do everything
you're good at great at everything i do
and yet you're
you're living this very self-destructive
life
yeah
is it because there's too many choices
for you is because
no this is
just really is just what i want to do
really
you've been loved you've been in love
before oh yeah
many times
and the prospect of that happening again
doesn't no i don't want to do it again
a lot of people feel that way
do you have anyone that
understands
yeah understands you yeah who's that
um
the last one the last girlfriend yeah
yeah
where is she today
she's in oakland i think
yeah 10 years
10 years all she could put up with
yeah it's got to be a hard for
you've got to be a difficult partner
for definitely
what's been the roughest thing you've
gone through
just probably definitely
losing her
i was definitely you know
the catalyst for this
there's a run that i'm on yeah
but
that's like
i'll get over it or i won't
so you've been in kensington how long a
year and a half yeah
it's rough here i mean
not for me
you like the gunshots you like the
definitely nothing new for me the
hustlers and the
drug addicts everywhere
this is
this is
you know
this is my surprise
this is your scene yeah it really is
you're comfortable with it
you're not interested in rehab you're
not interested in housing you're not
interested in
anything comfortable
no
what does your dad say
my dad's ted
are you dad's dead when did your dad die
it's been like probably five or six
years now
how'd your dad die
um
i can ask something medical yeah not
drugs i don't know if this can do
no
there's no other joke addicts yeah sorry
about that
no one's gonna understand you
it's all right
i'm open to interpretation you seem
happy i mean
i try to be you're a good communicator
except for your except for your throat
yeah
which really sucks i mean
i really
that's a huge part of my life
communication yeah yeah
i rely on that
so this
really does affect me in ways i can't
explain
yeah
and you haven't been to a doctor about
it or anything like that
no
how do you get money for drugs i hate
people
oh i see so you have to fight them yeah
yeah you're always in the park helping
people
find a vein aren't you yeah
why do they pay you for that
it's usually five
or a bag of dope it's a dark existence
you've got monster
but i i imagine that
delights you someone somehow right
it's
it is what it is you know
seeing a therapist isn't in the cards
for you no
do you have friends
no
did you have dreams of doing something
with your life when you were younger
well
i've always done what i wanted
and now you're doing what you want and
right now
it could change though yeah definitely
it could definitely change it has before
this is my first rodeo
you know
but right now this is what i wanted
what are you worried about
no i said right now this is what i want
no but what do you worry about oh
nothing you're not afraid of anything no
not afraid of dying oh
you're afraid of
living i really hate being incarcerated
so
try to avoid that that'd be good that's
about it
are there benefits to this this
lifestyle yeah i do exactly what i want
no responsibility no job
well that's not exactly true
you got to hit the vein i've got it
i've got to be out there working
all day
if you had your life to live all over
again would you do anything differently
no
nothing
wow
you ever get uh depressed or angry
anxious anything like that
i mean i think i probably am depressed
but i do
pretty a pretty good job of dealing with
you know
what was your favorite memory as a kid
the only thing i have
i think all my favorite memories start
as an adult
what's your favorite adult memory
[ __ ] i don't know
i really don't know
i've done a lot i've had a lot of fun
i've lived a lot of lifestyles so
it's hard to say what would you say is
the most important lesson you've learned
in your life
just to
be nice to people
not to hate anybody or anything
to love everybody
and do what you want oh absolutely
absolutely
all right moser thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you and i hope
you've lived a long happy life i hope so
too hopefully i don't come back in a
year and find you going
i doubt it
i'm not so fortunate
thank you
you